JONATHAN BADEEN:
So first off, I'd
like to thank Google
for having us,
throwing this awesome event--
I got to do the London one last
year, and it was a lot of fun--
and for making a
platform allowing
us to do all of this great stuff
and make money, which I know we
all like.
So anyway, I'm Jonathan Badeen.
I'm cofounder and chief
strategy officer of Tinder.
I am, I guess,
known a little bit
for making that
"swipe right" thing,
so just trying to do better.
It's not going to
happen probably.
But today, Jeff and I would
like to share our success story
with going Gold, our latest
subscription offering, and how
we got to that.
And I think to do that, you need
to see where we started from
and how we got to
that point and the way
we think about these things.
So Tinder was launched in 2012.
We were really trying to help
people meet people around them.
You've got your phone now.
Everybody's looking
down at it at that time.
They're not really interacting
with the people around them.
We wanted to change that.
So we launched in 2012.
Today we're now
in 196 countries,
1.6 billion swipes per day.
That results in about 26
million daily matches.
That comes out to over 20
billion matches so far.
And that comes to--
what really matters--
1.5 million dates a week.
But to achieve all of that,
we had to craft an ecosystem.
And we looked at the things
that existed prior to us.
Most of these things came
from the desktop world.
And we looked at what we
felt could be improved upon
in addition to just doing
a mobile-first platform.
So we had quite a few goals for
the platform and the ecosystem.
But a few of them
stick out specifically
for how they relate to
our monetization later on.
So we really
focused on location.
It turns out that location is
this pretty important thing
when you're trying to match two
people up to physically meet
in the real world.
So we focused on that.
A lot of the things
before us had
allowed the user to search for
whatever or put where they were
and all.
But we made it require that
you use location services
from the app, the GPS.
That was the only
way you could do it.
So you could only see
the people around you.
The next is that we had
noticed that a lot of people,
especially women, were
getting tons of messages.
And it created a lot of noise.
So you had too many.
You got all these
messages from people
you didn't want to
be interacting with.
And then you couldn't
find the people
that you were interested in.
So it was pretty overwhelming,
especially for women,
to go through these
previous products.
The next couple
are pretty crucial.
We were trying to reduce
feelings of rejection
on the flip side.
And this kind of goes actually
hand-in-hand with the filtering
of noisy messages.
So you've now got
a system previously
where you're sending a whole
bunch of messages, hopefully
meaningful and lengthy
ones to try to stick out.
But you had this outbox
or this sent messages
list that was basically
just your rejection list.
So we really were
trying to solve that.
And in addition to
solve that, we actually
did one thing that
solved both the noisiness
and the rejection.
We added the double
opt-in, or what
we call the "double opt-in."
So only two people who
swipe right on each other
are allowed to
message each other.
That kept you from
getting unwanted messages.
And it kept others from
spending too much time
on a single user that
they weren't going
to get a response back from.
To reduce the
feelings of rejection,
we also did a
couple other things.
We decided you can't go back.
You can't dwell on a user.
Once you see them,
they're gone, because it's
kind of hard to feel rejected
by somebody you can't remember.
Alcohol works, too.
[LAUGHTER]
So we also wanted
it to be anonymous.
You don't feel quite as rejected
if the other person doesn't
know that you're out there.
The worst thing is
putting yourself out there
and then hearing no.
So nobody would know
whether you liked them
or not unless they
also like you.
And the last thing
we did was we tried
to create something
that's fun and simple.
That comes through in the
lightweight, game-like
interactions, the swipe itself.
And this gets us
to the point where
about two years after
launching, we're
now trying to figure out how
are we going to make money off
of this thing.
It's costing us a lot
of money to run this.
And we started to think of
how we wanted to do that.
And we decided that we
wanted to accomplish this
by adjusting the--
we needed to adjust some of
the rules of the game which
we felt we had learned from
from some unforeseen behaviors.
But we also wanted
to perhaps let
people break our initial rules.
So in 2015, we
launched Tinder Plus.
We launched it with
three different features.
And we did price
testing, which showed us
that we would start out
with a $9.99 price point.
Those features
included Passport.
Passport allowed you to break
the location rule so you
didn't have to go off the GPS.
And you could virtually
travel anywhere in the world.
Then we also had
Rewind, which allowed
you to go back, spend
a little bit more
time, maybe change your
mind on which way you
swiped for somebody.
Now, the next feature
was paired with a change
to the overall game.
We hadn't really expected
this when we created Tinder.
Whether with your finger
or a piece of meat,
what you're really
doing is creating
a lot of noise,
one of the things
that we were really
trying to get away from.
You didn't have these
earnest matches.
And so what we decided
to do was to limit
the number of right
swipes that you
could do per day to hopefully
make people think a little bit
more about their choices.
But because we like money
and because we thought maybe
there are reasons for you to be
able to have a little bit more,
we gave you unlimited
right swipes.
And this concludes
the first feature
set that we had launched.
But as time went on,
we added a few more
that included Super
Like and Boost.
Super Like allowed you to
break the anonymity rule.
It would allow you to express
interest in somebody, which
in turn actually I guess
maybe displays confidence
and makes it more likely
that that person is going
to swipe right on you-- them
knowing that you already
liked them.
And then we gave Boost.
Everybody has to stand in line.
That's only fair.
But Boost allows you to
cut in line a little bit
for a temporary amount of time.
We also added a slew
of other features.
I won't really go into them.
But what I think the
real point here is
we had a whole
bunch of features,
and our price point
stayed the same.
So we're giving you that much
more value than we originally
did with Tinder Plus.
So now that you kind of know
how we got to all of this
and where we were at
this point and how
it ties into our ecosystem
to the point of before making
Gold, I think it's time for
Jeff to share with us how
he went about doing that.
JEFF MORRIS: Sure.
Thank you guys.
Thanks to the Google
team, I had the pleasure
of traveling to Asia last year
with a whole bunch of you guys.
So it's really nice
to be here again.
So Jonathan just went through
how he created Tinder.
And I'm going to show
you how I broke Tinder
because that's what I do.
But I'm Jeff Morris.
I'm the director of
product and revenue,
responsible for
Tinder Gold, and also
built Boost and a
few other things.
So this is the team I work with.
It's about 18 people.
I'm showing you this
slide just so you
know to build a
global business, you
don't need this massive team.
So if you're sitting in
your office thinking,
that's great that
Tinder did that,
but I probably can't
do that, you can.
You just need the right
road map and set of ideas.
So as mentioned, Jonathan
just showed you all the rules
that he created.
My job when I walk in
the office every morning
is to think of what
rules we can break
and what features we can
give some subset of customers
but not everybody,
because it would literally
break the game of Tinder.
So if you think of
Boost as an example,
if everyone's Boosting
at the same time,
the whole world
would be Boosting.
And the game would just break.
And so I'm thinking of things
that we can give people
in limited cohorts
that will make
the game more efficient or fun.
And the key thing here is if
you think that any rule that you
build in your product-- so all
those rules that Jonathan just
showed you--
if you think those
are sacred, and you
walk into work every
day, and you're like,
we can never do that, your
job is to challenge that.
So go to work every day.
Think of what's in your
game, your application
that you can unlock for a
certain subset of people.
So if there's any two
things to take away today,
it's these two.
This is how I think
about monetization.
It's access and exposure.
And you can read all sorts
of books on game theory
and how you design games.
But if you just have
those two things in mind,
you can probably go
to work and come up
with some pretty cool ideas.
And this is a newspaper
article from the 1800s.
I show you this because
you don't always
need to invent something new.
What you can do is
make it a lot better.
So this is an ad.
A male paid $0.25 for
this, which is $4.50 now.
He took out an ad saying he's
an honorable gentleman waiting
for the right woman.
Tinder is obviously
a lot more efficient,
but we're not always
inventing new things.
And if you look at some
of the features we built,
you can probably find
something historically
that did something similar.
But our job is to
make them 10x better.
And so speaking of history,
this is what we built last year,
2017.
It's a feature called
Likes You, which
we package within Tinder Gold.
And I'm going to show you
the crazy development.
I've never showed
this, actually,
so we'll see how it goes.
I'll show you the development
process that went into this.
We made some really
bad decisions
and some good decisions.
But ultimately, really
happy where we landed.
And feel free to make
noise if you think this
is a good idea or bad idea.
But this was the first
version of Likes You,
which was the main feature.
So I broke one of Jonathan's
rules, which was I
want to show you who likes
you before you swipe.
We kept the double
opt-in, so you both need
to like each other to message.
But I really thought
that the game
could be more efficient if
I just knew who liked me.
And so ignore these
prices, by the way.
This is a designer who
clearly doesn't know how
to price things.
Our average price was
anywhere from $9.99 to $19.99.
We had this very
dense feature set.
So you saw that list of
items, probably 10 features,
that we had already
packaged within Tinder Plus.
And the debate we had
on the product team
was we're unlocking
what's probably
the most valuable thing we could
ever give away on Tinder, which
is showing you who likes you.
And now we're just
going to give it
to everyone within Tinder Plus.
That didn't seem
like a good idea.
And so we went back
and forth, and this
was the original design.
Again, we were going to
package it within Tinder Plus.
And so one day, one
of us came to work.
Actually, we were
text messaging.
And we said, what if
we just allowed people
to have multiple subscriptions?
You can literally
have two different--
you could have Tinder Plus and
Tinder Gold at the same time,
which we had seen games do.
And it seemed like
a really cool idea.
And then I met with our finance
team and our accounting team,
and they thought it
was a terrible idea.
And then we just talked more
about the customer journey
and what it might feel like
to have two different tiers
at the same time.
That would get pretty confusing.
We have seen games do this.
And it's kind of
a cool model which
I could see becoming a thing
one day, but not quite yet.
And then V3, where
we landed on, which
I'm really happy we discovered,
is a simpler version.
So it was a Tinder Plus upgrade.
Now we created Tinder Gold.
One key thing is we spent a
lot of time on the branding.
So we didn't just want to
call this Tinder Plus Plus.
We thought about what's
actually cool, fun,
what's going to get
people's attention.
So one of the things
which we didn't show here
is when you tilt the phone,
the gold tilts with you.
And it has this shiny
animation effect.
All of our paywalls have crazy
animations and fun things,
probably inspired by
people like Jonathan
who are product
perfectionists slash nerds.
Sorry, Jonathan.
We spend a lot of time
making our paywalls better,
which seems crazy.
But we geek out on that stuff as
much as we do the core product.
But basically, what
you're seeing here
is this is the upgrade flow.
So as you see here, you can
upgrade for $9.99 a month.
So at $19.99, you're basically
paying $29.99 a month.
If you're on the $9.99
tier, you're paying $14.99.
We still felt like
that was probably low,
but we thought $9.99 felt
like a good place to start.
And one of our concerns was--
I'm sure you're
sitting here saying,
you read articles
about different people
raising their prices.
And customers revolt. And
we definitely had that fear.
Would customers
think this is fair?
I'm paying for Tinder Plus.
Now I have to upgrade?
Would they think
it's too expensive?
Would they find enough
value in one feature
to justify an upgrade?
And we definitely were worried
about all these questions.
Ultimately, we solved
everything through testing.
So our older cohorts
showed us that they
were willing to upgrade.
And we proved that through
very limited tests.
But if you're scared
about customers revolting,
definitely a great concern.
But I would challenge
you to run tests
to see if that's the truth.
Also, as was mentioned, we
have a shorter life cycle.
So we have cohorts
coming in and out.
So hopefully there
aren't people who
have been on Tinder for five
years who are sitting at home
really upset about this, because
we have new customers coming
in every day and people leaving
because hopefully they found
somebody that they really like.
I'll just show you a breakdown.
This isn't anything that
appears in the application.
But if you really
look at what we did,
we created a new tier
off of one feature.
So if you have one thing you're
thinking about unlocking,
you can possibly create a new
tier just off one feature.
This would be a very
boring thing to see in-app.
It kind of looks like a
[? SaaS ?] billing page.
The key thing to see here
is we have this rich feature
set, which is Tinder Plus.
And we just tweaked it a little
bit and created Tinder Gold.
One of the challenges
we've run into
and we're still figuring out is,
how do you sell multiple tiers?
And so we had this
baby we created.
It's Tinder Plus.
Business is going really well.
Stock price is doing well.
The company is really
comfortable and happy.
And now we're going to
release Tinder Gold.
So how do we sell
two things at once
within this small real estate
that's your mobile phone?
Ultimately, we were very
conservative, actually.
So we probably have
dozens of entry points
to paywalls within our app.
But we really only
sold Tinder Gold
from two places, one being your
match list, which we had never
monetized before.
So if you tap on
that, that 10 says
this person has 10-plus
people who like them.
Or you can go to
your Settings page.
And we started to
emphasize Tinder Gold
more than Tinder Plus.
Again, people who
worked on Tinder Plus--
it's kind of like
telling them their baby
is no longer the focus
of our attention.
We're not moving on, but we're
willing to try something new
and focus on something new.
And that was definitely
a concern internally.
But again, we tested.
Also, certain cohorts
we emphasize Tinder Gold
to more than others.
So if there are
price-sensitive customers,
maybe you do want to get them
hooked on the intro package.
Again, you'll have
to test this a lot.
But merchandising definitely
becomes a challenge.
So we're about a year
into Tinder Gold.
We're just starting.
So if you think of the game pad
on Tinder, things like rewind,
things like running
out of likes,
we weren't even letting you
subscribe to Tinder Gold
until about a week ago
from those paywalls.
And the big concern there
is, what if conversion
flops from your main paywalls?
And then you're
suddenly in a world
where you're trying to revert
back to your old model.
We also considered
a tabbed version.
Again, like that [? SaaS ?]
page that I showed you,
we don't want our
paywalls to start
feeling like there are so
many different choices that I
have to make.
So right now we have a
single entry point option,
which is you can only buy Tinder
Gold from our core paywalls.
One cool thing that we saw--
and I think for any revenue
feature you build, you want to
build complementary features.
So rather than having things
that cannibalize other paid
features, we made Boost
more valuable as an example.
So here's a user who's sitting
in their likes lists boosting.
And they're collecting
more likes in real time--
so a very powerful
way to augment what
was already a great
feature with Boost.
So just as you're
building new features,
just think about how they'll
interact with your other paid
features.
And if you're designing a game
or anything that's social,
hopefully they'll make
that feature better.
Here's the results.
So proud to say we were number
one in Google Play last year.
I'm not sure where we
finished-- this is January.
We finished the
year in number two
behind Netflix for
non-gaming apps.
There were many
ways we got here,
but the Tinder
Gold tweak was what
really pushed us over the top.
We nearly doubled
subscribers, more than doubled
our revenue, 3.1
million average subs,
which was an
increase of 544,000.
And then again,
second-highest grossing app.
This is kind of the hockey
stick that we like to see.
Again, I'm not going to give
Tinder Gold all the credit
in the world because other
people from Match Group
might be here and might beat
me up in the alley afterwards.
But again, we saw this great
result in the public markets.
Our stock price
more than doubled.
And again, there were
many ways we got here,
but we were happy this happened.
One other result--
we're always searching
for features at Tinder that will
appeal to women subscribers.
The honest truth is
in the dating space,
men are far more likely to
pay for features than women.
It's just how our
vertical happens to work.
This was actually
a tweet yesterday.
It said "a few people convinced
me to try Tinder Gold,
and honestly, the quality of
my conversations and dates
went up a lot."
We did see an increase
for female subs of 7.4%
when we released
Tinder Gold, which
we're really excited about.
"GQ" said it's more
lady-friendly, which
is good news for everyone.
I'm not sure what's
going on here,
but we were happy
about this article.
So if I want to leave
you with any rule,
it's go back to your
office after today.
Go to people like
Jonathan and say that you
want to break your own rules.
That's how you monetize.
And go forth.
[APPLAUSE]